I mentioned the New England Patriots  earlier and their deflategate scandal  now of course I looked into it this is  not the first time the Patriots have  been accused of cheating for example  there's the time they widened their own  goalposts  I don't remember that he didn't think  anyone would notice there's the time  they put magnets in the opposing teams  helmets and that caused all kinds of  trouble yeah there's the time they made  opposing teams pay tolls every five  yards there was that illegal use of a  helicopter I just thought that was  actually I thought that was brilliant  there's a time they replace one of their  linemen with a grizzly bear four people  were killed and there's the time they  put Bill Cosby in charge of the opposing  teams Gatorade that's right  [Applause]  you  you